marie laffont
marie laforêt
échange d'une chanson qui ont marqué
notre vie bretonne
parce que marina foïs et pas seulement
la fille aux yeux d'or s'est pas
seulement 50 films c'est pas seulement
les livres le théâtre c'était aussi 35
millions d'albums vendus
c'est pas mal et c'est tant mieux c'est
fait alors et attire des maisons de
disques wii balance et la met sur les 35
millions vous avez peu très peu parce
que toutes ces compila qui sortent en ce
moment qu'on voit là le jour chez la
fnac y avait cette compil aly cissokho 2
ils ont fait cette compilation 2010 1,2
en proie à ses démons des barons non
enfin si c'est ce que c'est pas vrai
j'ai reçu 9000 euros
amitié à lederman et sa vie je n'ai pas
parlé des d'hermann [ __ ] comment ça
marche pour moi alors je vais te dire ce
que je pense d'ailleurs
tous ces succès voulait pas chanter sur
scène depuis 30 ans et + 1972 exactement
depuis 33 ans 33 ans l'âge du christ tu
te rends compte l'âge du christ que j'ai
pas chanter et vous allez leur chanter
sur scène du 12 au 17 septembre théâtre
des bouffes parisiens ouais depuis un
mois que je suis évidemment obligé de
faire votre top 6 des chansons je suis
enthousiasmé je suis enchanté je suis
ravi c'est ravissant c'est charmant
c'est gai c'est tonique
je suis innocente et de faire ça enfin
bien payé non ce que tu sais pas c'est
que derrière cette opération il ya une
logistique impressionnante un requin du
show biz qui est en train de devenir le
parrain un tycoon un violent ouais c'est
à dire que de ce côté là il faut quand
même je crois que j'ai en ouvrant un
côté c'est un petit rappeler que didier
violent également il a confirmé tout à
l'heure dans les loges dédié tu es chaud
c'est pas moi qui produit la même chose
que j'ai baisé la main et à d et la
maire je suis vengé d'avant
hu et trois gardes côtes soit un moment
tu ne regardes là il ya un producteur
absolument mais c'est un requin petits
plats marocains on se méfie pas parce
que au début
sympa oui il a l'air comme ça pas tenu
un grip minaudant massa blessé je lirai
pas de motivation
le choc
le
le bas côté ski genre humain étant petit
garçon le nouveau requins du show biz le
producteur de marie laforêt c'est
laurent ruquier
voilà pour en tout cas pour ce spectacle
c'est toi qui va produire dans la forêt
oui exactement c'est toi qui paye parce
que j'avais envie de la voir chanter
est ce que tu vas avoir assez et c'est
appris comment cet amour de marie
laforêt 2 depuis les petits attention à
ce que je dis depuis toujours c'est très
bien ça depuis toujours pour les
finances du club
moi je ne connaissais que les grands
succès se vous avez passé tout à l'heure
et que tout le public connaît mais après
grâce aux fameuses compile même si elle
n'a rien touché dessus c'est compile
auront eu au moins un mérite c'est que
j'ai découvert des tas de chansons que
j'ignorais et qui sont toutes plus
belles les unes que les autres ce qui
est plus de 300 chansons sur scène il
faut dire que marie va chanter ses
grands succès ça fait plaisir
la majorité du public mais elle va aussi
chanter les chansons que on va dire ses
fans ses aficionados ceux qui
connaissent tout sans perdre répertoire
les chansons sud-américaine mes chansons
moins connues mais qui sont toutes aussi
belles et plus belle même parfois que
les grands succès tu te souviens d'elle
à la télé tu l'a découvert à la télé